[Music]
bienvenidos
and welcome to the people the museum
collections we are here
surveying the national birds of
latin american countries i'm holding
here golden eagle
this is a specimen from the united
states but
this species is also found in northern
mexico in baja california and northern
states
and it's declining therefore it's on the
list of threatened species in mexico
you can actually see that unlike bald
eagle
the golden eagle and members of this
genus have feathered tarsai
the lower part of the leg just up to the
toes
so this feathering is uh unique
and i have here another raptor
this one is a national bird for panama
so i'm going to try to gently lift it
this is a harpy eagle
and it's a juvenile bird adult would
have a
big black band on the breast and if we
can maybe focus
quickly on the talons of this bird
this is really the largest and most
powerful eagle
in the americas in the world and these
talons here the claws
are the size of grizzly bears claws
this bird is uh pretty widely
distributed in panama it's mostly found
in
the darien region in the eastern panama
against the border of colombia
because it requires large swaths of
mature
forest one pair can occupy a territory
of 25
kilometers squared so this kind of
forests are harder and harder for these
birds to find and they have declined and
even
disappeared from parts of their range
but in panama it's still a reliable bird
to to see
then i wanted to show you the
spectacular resplendent quetzal
here's a male from honduras
but this bird is a national bird of
guatemala
and what you see here is that what looks
like a tail
is in fact upper tail cupboards so these
are
feathers that come over the tail and the
tail is this black and white
much shorter a set of feathers
so this very long tail let's call it
is in the birds from north of the range
but if you go
to countries like costa rica or panama
where the species reaches with its range
you see that the tails are much shorter
in this population
one other thing i wanted to point out
that uh
on this male here the red of its belly
is
uh rather faded and this actually what
happens when the bird is
uh on the exhibit for a long time this
bird is mounted
for display in for galleries and has
glass eyes
and clearly was exposed to light quite a
bit so this is a
challenge we face when we exhibit
specimens in the galleries
but here is a fresh specimen a female
and you can actually see how much
brighter red
her belly is but you can also notice
that structural colors those that don't
depend on pigments don't fade and in
this case it's
bright green beautiful preserved color
and then here is tucan this is actually
sulfuratus the what the secure build
token
in english and in the country of belize
this is a national bird and
they sometimes call this just bill bird
and that's obviously because of this
massive bill which in life would be
brightly rainbow colored with green red
orange
unfortunately in specimens in the
collection this these colors are gone
so we usually when we collect this
record the colors
with photography or just a description
in the field
and here we have a specimen
of a turquoise-browed motmot this bird
was chosen as a national bird
by two countries by
el salvador i believe uh where
it's called torogos and in
nicaragua where it's called
guardabarranco
in both cases these names make a lot of
sense
in one case toro goss is from one of
it's a onomatopoeic name
and it resembles the triple call that
birds
make in some situations like alarming
when they alarm
and the other name guarda barranco
simply refers it translates into guard
of the
barranca or the valley they nest in
cliffs excavate burrows in
banks of earth and sometimes connect
colonially
and one other interesting feature here
you see that the tail
has a part of the of the vein missing
this is actually a natural phenomenon
the tail ends with these beautiful
iridescent blue spatulas and
these are the only two central feathers
that do this trick
these naturally fall off the bird
doesn't have to pluck this
but feather starts with a complete vein
so that's kind of an interesting
phenomenon only found in mothmotz
and yeah this is a bird that normally
would be hard to find in the forest
most any species of mothmats can be
easily heard but not easily seen
because they sit motionless and there
are sit and wait predators
somewhere in the forest understory but
this particular trogon
uh in modmod sorry is actually quite
common and can be found in more open
habitats
i saw my first bird in the yucatan of
mexico
and it was sitting on a wire of the
power line
so it's can be found even in urban
suburban
areas then we have
this spectacular macaw
this bird is a national bird of honduras
scarlet macaw has a wide range
it's found not only in central america
but also in south america but
has declined and pet trade and habitat
loss is
some of the reasons they require large
cavities for nesting and
what usually you see bears in flying in
pairs or
small family groups and luckily it's
still relatively easy to find in most of
the countries
but in honduras where it's a national
bird it's now restricted to
musketeer region and
finally a rather drop bird this is a
national bird of costa rica
and it has a rather interesting name
iguiro it's what i call the nightingale
phenomenon where
a drab looking bird like in europe the
nightingales
has a spectacular song and it's really
valued for the song
but also it often sings at night so it's
often
at the time when people are on a date
and it's kind of a romantic scene
a nice song nice conditions
and farmers rely on the fact that the
birds start singing
very intensively at the beginning of
rains when rainy season begins so it's a
good time to start planting